العجينه ملمومه خذ بالك ولسه هتريح بص
العجينه هذا مجرد جزء بسيط من النصائح
العمليه التي تعطيها خلال برنامجها
التلفزيوني والذي يسمى غاليه او الست
غاليه فهو من بين البرامج الاكثر شعبيه في
مصر وتيجي تقولكم هي هتساعدكم ازاي غاليه
تتوجه لكل امراه مصريه وتعمل جاهده على
تغطيه نفقاتها مع القليل من الخيال
والمساعدات ولا يخلو الامر من روح الدعابه
يا قر
اطباق تحتوي على احساسها ورايها الشخصي
العجين دايما انا اقول عليه خير قاعد قدام
التلفزيون وهذا اتصال من احدى السيدات
تسالها كيف لها ان تتعامل مع مشاكلها
العائليه كل واحده تحضن على بيتها وتحضن
على جوزها وما تحطش في دماغها ان اهل
جوزها دول وحشين او
عدوها حبيه يحبوكي وحبوا بعض زي حبوا بعض
ترزقوا الحب
رزق ومع اقتراب اول انتخابات حره في مصر
دعاها المبين للدخول في الحمله الانتخابيه
لكن لما يبقى في ريس يبقى لازم يكون فاهم
يمشي البلد البلد واهلها مش لعبه عشان
غاليه وغيرها وغيرها يخ مالك تلفزيون الخ
من يناير والذي يبث البرنامج يقول ان
غاليه لديها قدره على ترجمه السياسه في
عبارات
بسيطه قبل ثلاث حلقات كانت في طريقها
لشراء الليمون واختارته بدقه وقالت لا
تخجل في اختيار رئيسك الخاص بعنايه كما
افعل في اختيار ليموني انظر بدقه كبيره في
الليمون واتاكد من انه جيد وليس قديما
التكلفه بتاعتها بسيطه جدا يعني انا
دلوقتي جايبه كيلو في هذا اليوم التركيز
ينصب على
الحلويات وقبل نهايه البرنامج اتصل احد
المشاهدين وسال غاليه لمن ستصوت
بالانتخابات المقبله والله بص انا هقعد
قدام التلفزيون واشوف مين اللي يصلح ومين
اللي البلد ومين الانسان الكويس اللي
هيفيد وفي نهايه البرنامج تمسك غاليه
بسكين وتلوح بها مازحه وتطلب من المشاهدين
ان يرددوا معها ما
تقول